he's kevin harland play-by-play voice
for nba on tnt
nfl on cbs and monday night football in
westwood one
he'll be in the booth this sunday jets
in the colts
last sunday he had uh steelers titans
and or no that's week four is that right
todd he did baltimore and houston
baltimore houston was week two oh okay
so we're already getting ahead to week
four i only needed
this week i didn't need week four i'd
just like to give you more information
bring in kevin harlan hi kevin hey dan
how are you good morning
oh you know we're just trying to deal
with a non-professional staff here
we do it as well as anybody here
a lot of long time listener so i uh i
know all the personalities and love your
show
so it's fun to be on how often do you
get recognized by your voice
more than um when people see me i
like if i'm in a line and ordering food
or if i s am i talking to my kids as
we're walking or my wife or whatever and
they may hear it and they'll say
i know that voice you're uh and they
don't
don't know but they know so
um that's kind of fun you know not
really i don't i don't
uh um i know i i it's it's
it's it's something that kind of follows
us all in the business i'm sure just
like you
you talk and people know your voice
instantly and but they see you as well
and they don't see us as much because
it's on radio on
a monday night and then we're just on
for such a short time when we make our
opens on
tnt and cbs so it's not not as
common but voice yes sometimes people
will know i had a woman
uh an operator and i was calling for
a phone number and the woman
paused the operator paused and she said
say something again and and so i said i
need the number
and then she goes i go to bed with you
and i go what and she said
my my boy you're on tv my boyfriend has
what show are you on i said sportscenter
she goes my boyfriend has
you work at night i go yes and then we
got done
and then she hung up i didn't even get
the phone number from her
when i was asking her for it so i i get
it sometimes
but you're right you know i've been on
tv or at least my face has for
for a long time and uh but people will
hear the voice sometimes and go oh
it's mr sports they may not know my name
i'm just like oh you're mr sports center
there
well it's instantly recognizable i gotta
ask you a question though because i
thought this for a long time and i
thought maybe we'd cross paths and
i'd ask in person i mentioned this to
todd uh when we're
texting back and forth but did you
listen a lot to larry king and his
interview style
uh by chance when you were a younger
broadcaster and getting your
place in the business because i i i say
this because
um and and i'm not trying to you know
to deter the conversation here but but
your questions and your pacing and all
that but the best i had ever heard in
news was larry king i thought his
his interviewing style was great and i
started listening to you religiously for
on how many years you've been doing the
radio show and i thought this this is
even better than king
because your your personality is a
little bit more
warm and larry of course was more
directed on news
topics and serious matters and
um i i don't know i i see a parallel
there but i'm just curious to see if you
listen to lobbying when you were growing
up and and and becoming the broadcaster
that you are
i would listen to larry he was doing
overnight
with his talk show and i would mutual
yeah and i was doing morning drive
radio in a rock and roll station and i
would be coming in around
4 30 and then i would hear larry usually
about
for 40 minutes or so and what i always
remembered was like the curiosity
that you have anybody who interviews be
a good listener but be curious
and care about what somebody's answers
are that's really the most important
things that i
i teach i teach my broadcasting students
and larry has been at the forefront of
that for you know many many many decades
um and there are a lot of people who are
really good at it
but when people go boy you ask great
questions and i always say
it's not a great question unless it
solicits a great answer
that's what makes you know for a great
interview and i always tell broadcasters
ask a question that's open-ended get
somebody talking back to you because
that's what people are tuning in to hear
not how great your question is but
but thank you for that compliment who
did you look up to
when you wanted to be a play-by-play
voice
the first voice i remember when i was
about eight nine years old was fasendas
on nfl films
and then i um you know really listened
to race i grew up in green bay
um my dad was with the packers for
almost four decades and so
living there football was intense ray
scott
and ray scott yes and and some other
voices like
i'd go to bed at night and listen on
wcfl in chicago
jim durham doing the bulls and joe tate
on 3we
do the cavs the the the two voices that
i
probably admire the most aside from
facebook scott and summerhall
summerall's voice to me was great and
don cricky was was chuck thompson
out of baltimore and jim simpson
at uh later espn but but initially at
nbc
yeah and those were that like i would
tape them
on my cassette recorder when i was you
know like just a just a kid
and fall asleep with that playing
underneath my pillow at night
and would listen to their cadence and
their calls
and then as i was you know just getting
in the business when i was like 13 14
i tried to mimic them but i would like
use the array of voices like i'd spend
10 minutes trying to sound like jim
simpson and 10 minutes trying to sound
like
chuck thompson or jim durham or pat
sumrall
and um and i always tell kids that ask
me about voice and presentation delivery
i say you know you need a road map you
don't want to reinvent the wheel
you need a road map and and what those
voices and trying to
sound like as you listen to all the
different things the tonality and
and how they they move through a
sentence and a call
is you you kind of condition the muscles
in your voice
to kind of exude that then you get off
on your own
road and you sound like you're gonna
sound
but uh but those are the voices i hear
in my head
i hear i hear chuck thompson simpson
summerall and fasenda those those are
those are the voices i listen to when i
when i leave my hotel room for cbs every
morning going out to the stadium for our
sunday broadcast
i'll play the uh john fasenda the autumn
wind is a raider
because i love i just feel like first of
all i'm lucky enough to be in the nfl
i'm living a dream every time i step in
an nfl
broadcast booth and i i i think about
the appreciation i have for guys like
him
that probably sent many broadcasters
into the business
uh listening to his delivery and voice
and cadence and
and just what he meant really to kind of
igniting
the nfl and the majesty of it and
everything else so i it's it's kind of
like a little habit
i get into and um
uh it's it's it's something i'm kind of
stuck with every year i've been at cbs
and before that at fox
i remember when the raiders played the
redskins
and this was joe theismann and jack
squirrick was the linebacker for the
raiders who had an interception
and john fasenda had that line the
silver and black-clad masters of
intimidation nearly took joe
theismann's head off and then you had
that
1812 overture and i went oh you got me
the silver and black-clad masters of
intimidation
nearly took joe theismann's head off
god i love that uh i've got a very short
ficenta story when i was in college
uh i was when i was in college i was
producing
the kansas city chiefs radio network um
pre-game halftime post game shows all
all across the midwest
and we had this three-hour pre-game show
and i i wrote fasenda at nfl films i was
about 19 years old and i wrote for senda
at nfl films and i asked him would you
mind
reading this intro this intro to
our broadcast and and and the outro
would you mind doing just a couple of
like 25 seconds long each um i don't
know what you what you
charge but it would mean a lot to us and
um i about a week later i get this phone
call
in my fraternity house at the university
of kansas
and kevin this is john fasenda calling
and i go oh my god
and he says would you mind if i
rearranged this one sentence
and i said you do whatever you want to
do i'm just so thankful you'll do it so
i get the reel to reel tape about a week
after that
and i'm listening to it but they have
all of his you know outtakes and all
it's just raw
tape and finally he gets it right the
one that he liked the version that he
recorded
uh and at the end of it you know there
was this pause and i don't know if steve
sample was on on the other
side of the glass but but he said after
this long pause
uh no that's a horse that i can ride
i just love that i just love that story
and i
and i i still have the tape of him
saying that that raw that raw tape so i
uh that's great for sending this for
send it to me was
the voice of the nfl is he in the hall
of fame
uh you know that's a good question you
know joe just going in
i start thinking about that and i texted
joe last week after that announcement
and
of course you know he just looks up to
his dad and
thinks his dad hung the moon and rightly
so that was a wonderful relationship
between father and son and the fact that
the son
has almost become more popular than the
father and as you know jack buck in the
60s 70s and 80s
90s was like the voice of sports in this
country with so many sports covered
football baseball everything else
so um but that pete roselle award
is one coveted by every broadcaster if
ascendant is not in
i would be shocked i know the sables are
in ed and steve
yeah that took a while though for them
to get in which is a shame but
i i mean paulie would you check and say
i don't think john fasenda is in the
hall of fame but
i i mean his contributions with those
you know those highlights i mean that he
should be in there in the hall of fame
we're talking to kevin harland
play-by-play voice for nba on tnt
uh nfl on cbs he's got the jets and the
colts
this sunday yeah let me see you make
that sound like an interesting game
good luck good luck with that kevin
no crowd noise you're going to have to
really ratchet it up there a little bit
i know i know but those are the great
challenges you've been you've done play
by play you know what that's like
sometimes you get a
you know we had a great game going in
last week and it really wasn't much of a
game baltimore at houston
we think you know two great young
quarterbacks and only lamar jackson
really was the one that made a dent
and then this week we got this next week
tennessee pittsburgh which might be
pretty good at least on paper so
you never know what you're going to get
actually the raider new orleans game we
did in vegas a couple nights ago that
should not be a terrific game yeah
with the raiders looking really good so
so you never know what you're going to
get you just always go in
as as you know as prepared as possible
and do the best job you can alright we
have a contest here and it's called the
kevin harlan game
so it's good that we have you on with us
for the kevin harland game
so so like if joe buck was on it would
be really odd to do the kevin
games joe wouldn't do it okay so
you and todd are going to have some
calls some play-by-play calls and then
we
the audience has to figure out is it
kevin harlan
making this call or todd fritz now we
don't know who's going to go first
so contestant number one you may
approach the microphone
with your play-by-play call jason tatum
from the corner he buries the three and
the celtics take a double-digit lead
eric spoelstra will gather the troops
here and try to stop the bleeding
we step away briefly this is the nba on
tnt
all right contestant number two
all right tatum from the cornery perry's
the three in the celtics take a
double-digit lead sculpture will gather
the troops here and
try to stop the bleeding as we step away
this
is the nba on tnt okay
i can't tell the difference right now uh
round two
the false start makes it third and eight
now for the seahawks just inside their
own 15
wells in the snap drops back to throw
complete to dk metcalf
across the 30 and steps out of bounds at
the 34.
it's the first down for the seahawks
okay
contestant number two the false start
makes it a third and eight for seattle
just inside their own 15.
wilson back to pass complete to gk
metcalf across the 30.
out of bounds at the 34. that's a first
down for the seahawks
okay i'm gonna need one more because i
can't really determine
who is kevin harlan final round here to
decide
the kevin harlan game if you're just
joining us patrick mahomes is at it once
again the chiefs trailed by 20 at one
point
now they're down just four with under a
minute to go the single setback edwards
hilaire mahomes rolls back
he's got travis kelsey in the back
corner both feet in touchdown
kansas city wow that was a great
call kev i mean i'm not sure who made
that call
here's the final call if you're just
joining us mahomes is at it again
chiefs trail by 20 now they're down just
four with under a minute to go the
single back
is edward zelaire malms rolls right he's
got kelsey in the back corner
both feet in touchdown the chiefs have
scored
i don't know i it felt like the voice
that did the first version of that uh
touchdown pass who was todd can you tell
me who was uh
you and who was kevin there okay on the
first one which was the celtics with
jason tatum
um i went todd todd i know
kevin if you ever miss a game and you
need somebody to fill in for you
and be you then todd fritz is your guy
i'll definitely make that call and i'll
tell the people it's cbs
he's ready to go willing and ready to go
so you're sure we didn't have to let you
know who was kevin
no no no i positive you know i i was
i was able to i mean i could have let
the mystery linger forever but
i just thought i got to be fair to the
audience and let them know
i just do uh kevin you're a great sport
uh
safe travels have fun uh with the jets
and colts this sunday
at 4 eastern on cbs my privilege dan
thank you and thanks to your great crew
i
as i began by saying i listen all the
time and love the show and
love all the guys that are a part of it
it was really fun to be on thank you
thank you kevin that's uh kevin harlan
yeah i
i at one point i wasn't able to tell the
difference between
i love that todd actually had to explain
okay the first one i went first
yes
so that was me with the first question i
know i got it i got the second one he
went
first and then i read first no no i got
it and that's that was great thanks down
kansas city although i will say
that call was better than kevin's call i
think it was
it was the last one you were better than
kevin
i was more excited i said touchdown
kansas city goes and kansas city is in
for the score like
we lost them yeah yeah okay